here are some upcoming panels you should  pay attention that still have short  lines very short lines if you want to  check them out on Sunday there's the guy  who made the shawarma for the Avengers  tells all yeah I'm gonna see that one  there's yeah check this one out there's  meat the last four actors who haven't  played spider-man yeah there's this one  klingon genitalia a closer look that's  check out this one there's a tribute to  Stanley's greatest typos featuring this  silver sufferer come on my dad wrote  that one and then there's the cast of  guardians of the galaxy if it starred  different people such as Emilio Estevez  Emilio Estevez not available yeah  there's a very short line there's  Windhoek smash are you covered  what you need to know about superhero  liability insurance and finally my  favorite Ron Perlman will glare at you  for 30 seconds  I would do that  you